so there's this guy mr beast he's on
youtube okay he's huge on youtube we're
pulling him up this guy jimmy
donaldson is his name aka mr beast and
he was recently on the
logan paul podcast called impulsive
and he revealed something very shocking
so
basically this guy jimmy i think he's
number one on youtube maybe number two i
think ryan's world is right up there but
this guy jimmy donaldson mr beast earns
about 24 million dollars a year he's got
just shy of 50 million subscribers he's
got 3 billion views on youtube the guy's
a beast he's a mr freaking beast anyway
he talked to logan paul about what does
he do with the money marcelo what did he
do with the money let's find out what he
does with the money so he gets onto the
the logan paul podcast
and
he basically saying how much he spends
on his youtube videos and if you've ever
seen his videos it's ridiculous it's
insane he's like so always getting in a
box or something
he basically goes on to tell
uh logan paul that he spends four
million dollars to make his videos and
logan paul is like what
back up a second so let me just let me
just frame this conversation so he's 23
years old by the way he's a year younger
than you which makes you want to almost
throw up in the mouth a little bit so he
he appears on the impulsive podcast with
um
logan paul
and logan paul asked him very directly
dude are you a billionaire yet
and mr beast looks at him and he's like
no
i'm actually probably the poorest person
in the room
when it comes to cash when it comes to
cash because you know maybe on paper
i'm uh uh you know rich but actual cash
i'm the prores person and and and i i
think logan paul is like what the
you talking about
what are you talking about right here
and he basically says well look if i
make three or four million dollars a
month i just spend it all on my videos
or on xbox
and logan paul shocked
confused flabbergasted he's like hold on
what do you mean you spend four million
dollars on youtube videos
what the yeah which is basically
the same question that i have and i'm
sure we all do
and he's like well you know yes four
million dollars a month in total on all
my videos
and
logan paul is absolutely flabbergasted
and he says mr basically says look
i go all out on my videos i don't know
if there's anything we can show with
this guy this guy goes all out i don't
want to get anything taken away
okay we won't do that we will not do
that okay anyways i was gonna do this
ready i'd do anything for these people
i would do anything for them yes
i'd live for the audience
respect to you marcelo
anyway
he makes four million dollars and
apparently he spends it all on his
business so what's the point here
you make three four million dollars a
month
okay what's three times twelve that's 36
million dollars a year four times twelve
that's 48 million dollars a year this
guy is a youtube
sensation okay and he spends it all on
his videos and apparently on xbox i'm
sure you know we also got to give him
some credit like i'm sure this guy's got
some investment i mean this guy he's got
to be doing something he's not living at
his mom's house anymore i i do not think
so i hope i hope
that okay number one
respect to you let's just let's just get
a few things out of the way respect to
mr beast what he does is
insane and his earnings
24 million in earnings the guy the guy
is absolute beast or as you like to say
a savage
when it comes to youtube videos and
making money
um my eight-year-old nephew asked me
have you ever met mr beast
no i haven't but the guy is absolute
savage i just think i hope that if he's
doing this much with xbox maybe he's
taking a portion of his income and
investing in xbox stock
something like that
i hope so so here he says uh in one of
this thing he says um we literally have
razor thin margins and then just
reinvest it all so i feel like he's just
going from video to video you know
reinvesting it all but he probably makes
he's probably like you know like an
athlete that spends all of his game
money yeah but then he keeps all of the
you know sponsorship or
it's actually the opposite they'll spend
their sponsorship endorsement money
exactly they'll spend their endorsement
money their sponsorship but they keep
their game checks but they'll keep their
game that's what that's what gronk
basically
i would do if you're making 24 25
million a year 30 million a year what i
would do is say all right
i love what i do i absolutely love it
the fans love what i do everyone that
watches my videos is shocked i get
billions and billions of views and
comments and i would continue to
reinvest in my business and not stop
because unlike an athlete this guy can
go till he's 100 years old doing these
kind of videos it's not like his knees
are going to go out and he can't do a
video it's not like he's going to you
know do a crack back from a linebacker
and he gets a concussion he's out for
you know a season so he's got he's got
longevity there
what i would do is continue doing what
you're doing but set
earmark
and invest the hell out of that whether
that's in
real estate whether that's in in the
stock market mutual funds index funds
whether that's in crypto whatever it is
and start to build your wealth because
you never know what will happen
does happen and if you're making this
much money you never want to say bro i
was making 20 million dollars a year and
now i'm broke i don't know what happened
take a couple million bucks each year
put that aside get rental property
whatever you want to do
do that and then you can take
if you can't live on eighty percent to
make these videos then i don't know what
to tell you okay don't forget the
tithing sauce praise jesus
thank you paul uh did we we were gonna
cut paul's mic right
um
anyway i would uh i would tell mr beast
keep doing what you're doing people love
your videos respect to you just make
sure that you're saving that money yeah
and using some of that as an investment
his time is on his side he's 23 years
old this guy if he plays his cards right
this guy could have 100 million bucks by
the time he's 40 years old yeah and and
never have to actually worry about
um
or go and check to check or let me get
dark on you real quick yes or
he you know he makes all this money he's
constantly reinvesting it in the videos
and next thing you know he runs out of
ideas mr beast hits a wall he's run out
of hoops to jump through he doesn't know
what to do and he's sitting on a bunch
of x-boxes and you know a bunch of
basketballs that are zero gravity who
knows what he's messing with nowadays
i say i say mr beast i've seen you do a
lot of crazy stuff i'm a fan i see the
numbers you're doing
save that money mr beast his money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken